on est plus dans le système
sensibilisation bon les papiers c'est
important c'est uneation je sais je sais
bon vous êtes en vous avez mis
l'attestation deassurance ce qui est
déjà une bonne chose on fait une
vérification fichier d'accord d'accord
cet habitant de Rambouillet est plutôt
chanceux arrêté sur la route nationale
10 au niveau de coignère ce motard
aurait pu être verbalisé j'ai changé de
blous hier et donc j'avais mon permis de
conduire j'avais l'attestation de vigett
mais j'avais pas la carte grise on est
mieux dans le la dans l'information ou
que ou et l'accompagnement que dans le
répressif à la place du traditionnel
contrôle les services départementaux de
la sécurité routière sensibilise les
deux roues au bon comportement d'autant
plus que la veille sur la commune un
accident grave a eu lieu entre un motard
et une voiture il roulent à une certaine
vitesse il est vrai mais entre les fils
du véhicule ils sont assez prudents
surtout en sachant que quand vous roulez
entre les fils du véhicule vous avez
toujours le le conducteur de voiture qui
veut faire un dépassement qui met pas
son clignotant et c'est là qu'on arrive
sur accrochage le meard sera Hur c'est
certain mais on on essaie de leur faire
comprendre justement de de faire très
très attention pendant cette matinée les
forces de l'ordre ont effectué près de
80 contrôles C motards ont été arrêtés
pour vitesse excessive 15 personnes sont
convoquées ce vendredi au tribunal de
grande instance de Versailles pour voir
leur affaires classé grâce à cette
opération de sensibilisation en 2013 C
motards ont trouvé la mort sur les route
ilinoise